sentences the accused nunchi through
life imprisonment the chamber sentences
be accused kill some porn through life
imprisonment a verdict received without
emotion by eighty eight-year-old
nunchi and eighty three-year-old q Sam
pond the two most senior surviving
leaders of the Khmer Rouge many older
Cambodians watched the announcement for
survivors of the regime it felt a long
time coming
I thank the court for sentencing these
two criminals to life imprisonment I'm
extremely satisfied this is an example
for the next generation not to repeat
those three years eight months and 20
days between 1975 and 79 Khmer Rouge
soldiers perpetrated indescribable
atrocities in the name of their radical
communist ideology their aim to turn
Cambodia into a farmer state forced
evacuations murders and executions were
commonplace over 1.7 million people died
a quarter of the venn population known
as brother number two noon she served as
dictator Pol Pot's deputy Cuse and Poong
seen here on the Left acted as head of
state the public face of the regime 35
years later justice has come to these
men and belated relief to those who
suffered under them